welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on information retrieval
we come to the heart of it neural
information retrieval this is the class
of models that has done so much to bring
NLP and IR back together again and open
new doors for both of those fields
in the background throughout this
screencast I think you should imagine
that the name of the game is to take a
pre-trained Bert model and fine-tune it
for information retrieval
and in that context cross encoders are
kind of conceptually the simplest
approach that you could take
for cross encoders we're going to
concatenate the query text and the
document text together into one single
text process that text with Bert and
then use representations in that Burt
model as the basis for IR fine tuning in
a bit more detail we'd process the query
in the document and then probably take
the final output state above the class
token add some tasks specific parameters
on top and fine-tune the model against
our information retrieval objective so
that will be incredibly semantically
expressive because we have all of these
interesting interactions between query
and document in this mode
in a bit more detail in the background
here I'm imagining that we have a data
set of triples where we have a query one
positive document for that query and
some number one or more negative
documents for that query
the basis for scoring is as I described
it before we're going to take our Bert
encoder concatenate the query in the
document and process that text and then
retrieve the final output state above
the class token that's given here and
that's fed through a dense layer that is
used for scoring
and then the loss function for the model
is typically the negative log likelihood
of the positive passage so in the
numerator here we have our score for the
positive passage according to our
scoring function and the denominator is
that positive passage score again sum
together with the total for all the
negative passages
so let's step back this will be
incredibly semantically rich but it
simply won't scale the richness comes
from us using the Burt model to jointly
encode the query and the document so we
have all these rich token level
interactions but that is the model's
downfall this won't scale because we
need to encode every document at query
time so in principle this means that if
we have a billion documents we need to
do a billion forward passes with the
Bert model one for every document with
respect to our query get all those
scores and then make decisions on that
basis and that will be simply infeasible
so although there's something
conceptually right about this approach
it's simply intractable for modern
search
DPR can be seen as a model that's kind
of at the other end of the spectrum this
stands for dense passage retriever in
this mode we're going to separately
encode queries and documents so on the
left here I've got our query encoded
with a burt-like model and I've kind of
grayed out all of the states except the
final output state above the class token
that's the only one that we'll really
need
I separately encode the document and
again we just need that final output
state above the class token
and then we're going to do scoring as a
DOT product of those two vectors in a
bit more detail again we have a data set
consisting of those triples for our
query one positive document and one or
more negative documents
now our core comparison function is what
I've called Sim here and the basis for
Sim is that we encode our query using
our query encoder and get the final
output State and we get the dot product
of that with the encoding for our
document again focused on the output
state above the class token
the losses as before this is the
negative log likelihood of the positive
passage so the positive score up here
and then again use down here sum
together with the sum for all of the
negative passages
this will be highly scalable but it's
very limited in terms of its query
document interactions let's unpack that
a bit the core of the scalability is
that we can now encode all of our
documents offline ahead of time and
indeed we only need to score store one
single Vector associated with each one
of those documents and then at query
time we just encode the query get that
one representation above the class token
and do a fast dot product with all of
our documents so it's highly scalable in
that sense too
but at the same time we have lost all of
those token level interactions we had
with the cross encoder now we have to
hope that all of the information about
the query and the document is summarized
in those single Vector representations
and we might worry that that results in
a loss of expressivity for the model
before moving on to some additional
models in the space I thought it would
just pause here and point out that we
have a little bit of modularity
the loss function for both of the models
that I've presented is the negative log
likelihood of the positive passage
here's how I presented it for the cross
encoder and the core of that is this rep
function and here's how I am presented
it for DPR where the core of it is the
Sim function and you can now see that
there's a general form of this where we
just have some comparison function and
everything else Remains the Same and
this is freeing because if you developed
variants of DPR or cross encoders the
way that might play out is that you've
simply adjusted the comparison function
here and everything else about how
you're setting up models and optimizing
them could potentially stay the same
all right let's move to Colbert this
model is near and dear to me Colbert was
developed by Omar khattab who is my
student along with mate zaharia who's my
longtime collaborator and co-advises
Omar with me and Omar would want me to
point out for you that Colbert stands
for contextualized late interaction with
Bert
that's an homage to the late night talk
show host Stephen Colbert who has late
night contextual interactions with his
guests
but you are also free to pronounce this
covert because obviously the Bert in
that name is the famous Bert model
here's how Colbert works first we encode
queries using Bert I've drawn this on
its side for reasons that will become
clear when I show you my full diagram
but it's just a Burt encoding of the
query and I've grayed out all the states
except the final ones because the only
States we need are the output States
from this model
similarly why we encode the document
again with Bert and here again the only
States we need are the output States
and then the basis for Colbert scoring
is a matrix of similarity scores between
query tokens and document tokens again
as represented by these final output
layers so we get scores and in fact we
get a full grid of these scores
and then the basis for scoring is a
maximum comparison for every query token
we get the value of the maximum
similarity for document tokens and we
sum those together to get the maximum
value that is the basis for the model
in a bit more detail again we have a
data set consisting of those triples
the loss is the negative log likelihood
of the positive passage but now Maxim is
the basis and here is the maxim scoring
function in full detail but again the
essence of this is that for each query
token we get the maxim for some document
token and sum all those maximum values
together
this will be highly scalable but it has
late contextual interactions between
tokens in the query and tokens in the
document let me unpack that it's highly
scalable because as with DPR we can
store all of our documents ahead of time
we just need to score this Vector of
output vectors here to represent
documents at query time we encode the
query and get the output States and then
perform a bunch of very fast Maxim
comparisons for scoring
but it's also semantically Rich we have
retained some of the advantages of the
Cross encoder because we do have token
level interactions between query and
document it's now it's just that they
happen only on the output States whereas
the cross encoder allowed them to happen
at every layer in the Bert model that
was too expensive and this looks like a
nice compromise and Colbert has indeed
proven to be an extremely powerful and
effective IR mechanism
one thing I really like about Colbert is
that it brings in an older Insight from
IR which is that essentially we want to
do some level of term matching between
queries and documents except now since
this is a neural model we get to do that
in a semantically very rich space let me
show you that by way of an example here
I have the query when did the
Transformers cartoon series come out and
we have the document the animated
Transformers was released in August 1986
and I'm going to show you some Maxim
values
the largest score is between
Transformers in the query and
Transformers in the document
that makes good sense but we also have a
very strong Maxim match between cartoon
in the query and animated in the
document and that's a very semantic
connection that only neural models like
Colbert can make without extra effort
similarly for come out in the context of
the query we have a strong match to
release in the document
and then for when in the query that
matches to the two parts of the date
expression August 1986. here I've shown
the top two Maxim values to show that
we're really getting a semantic
connection to that full unit in the
document
so this kind of thing makes the model
highly interpretable and also reveals to
us why this is such an effective
retrieval mechanism because it can make
all of these deep associations
before moving on to splayed the final
model that I wanted to talk about I
thought I would pause here and just talk
a little bit with you about how you take
Colbert or any of these neural models
and then turn them into something that
could be effective as a kind of deployed
search technology because in the
background here is that we have semantic
expressiveness but it comes at a price
we need to do forward inference in Burt
models and that can be very expensive
prohibitively so if we have very tight
latency restrictions and so the question
for us is can we overcome those
limitations and make this a practical
solution
one easy thing to do to make this
practical is to employ these models as
re-rankers here this is how this would
play out for Colbert
for Colbert remember we have an index
that essentially consists of token level
representations those are each
associated with documents given an index
structure like this a simple thing to do
would be to take our query and code it
as a bunch of tokens
get the top K documents for that query
using a fast term-based model like bm25
and then use Colbert only at stage two
to re-rank the top K documents there
so we use bm25 for the expensive first
phase where we need to do Brute Force
search over on our entire index of
documents and the model like Colbert
comes in only at phase two to do
re-ranking
it sounds like a small thing but in fact
the re-ranking that happens in that
second phase can be incredibly powerful
and add a lot of value as a result of
the fact that Colbert and models like it
are so good at doing retrieval in this
context but they're expensive one nice
thing about this though is that we can
kind of control our costs because if we
set K very low we'll do very little
processing with Colbert if we set K High
we'll use Colbert more often and we can
kind of calibrate that against other
constraints that we're operating under
the
so this is a perfectly reasonable
solution the one concern you might have
maybe as a purist is that you now have
two retrieval mechanisms in play bm25
which does a lot of the work in Colbert
which performs the re-ranking function
we might hope for a more integrated
solution so could we get beyond
re-ranking for Colbert I think the
answer is yes
we're going to make a slight adjustment
to how we set up the index now the
primary thing will be that we'll have
these token level vectors which of
course as before associate with
documents
now when a query comes in we encode that
into a sequence of vectors
and then for each Vector in that query
representation we retrieve the P most
similar token vectors
and then travel through them to their
Associated documents and then the only
bear work that we do is scoring this
potentially small set of documents that
we end up in phase two because in Phase
One all we're doing is a bunch of
similarity calculations between Vector
representations so again we have a lot
of control over how much we actually use
the full Colbert model at step two here
and therefore we can calibrate against
other constraints that we're operating
under
so this is certainly workable but we can
probably do even better
and the way we can do even better is
with centroid based ranking and this
begins from the Insight that this index
that we've constructed here will have a
lot of semantic structure and we can
capture that by clustering the token
level vectors that represent our
documents into clusters and then taking
their centroids to be representative
summaries of those clusters and we can
use those as the basis for search
so now given a query that we encode
again as a sequence of vectors for each
one of those vectors we retrieve the
closest centroids and then travel from
them to similar document tokens and then
from them to similar documents and then
again we use Colbert the full model only
at step three here all these other
comparisons are just fast similarity
comparisons and this gives us huge gains
because instead of having to search over
this entire index we search over a
potentially very small number of
centroid representations and use those
as the basis for getting down to a small
set of documents that we're going to
score completely with Colbert
that's a bunch of the work that we've
done I thought I would just mention a
little bit of the work that we've done
specifically to address latency concerns
for Colbert and this comes from the
paper that we called plaid and it begins
from the observation that despite all
the hard work that I just described for
you the latency for the Colbert model
was still kind of prohibitively high at
287 milliseconds whereas you might hope
you could get this down to around 50
milliseconds for a feasible Deployable
solution at a minimum
and this chart here is showing you where
the work actually happens and one
surprising thing for Colbert is that
only a small part of the overall time
there is actually spent on the core
modeling steps of representing examples
and doing scoring
and in fact only a small part is even
used with the centroids that I described
before the bulk of the work is being
done when we have to look things up in
this giant index and also when we do
decompression that's a point that I
haven't mentioned before but the essence
of this is that
The Colbert index can get very large
because we need to store token level
representations but we find that we can
make them relatively low resolution four
or even two bit representations because
all they need to do is represent
individual tokens but that does mean
that we would like to decompress them at
some point to get back to their full
semantic richness and we found that that
step of kind of unpacking them was also
expensive
and so what the team did is do a lot of
work to kind of reduce the amount of
heavy duty lookup and decompression that
the Colbert model was doing
they trade that a little bit off against
using more centroids as part of that
initial search phase phase that I
described but they did successfully
remove almost all the overhead that was
coming from these large data structures
and the corresponding decompression that
we had to do and they got the latency
all the way down to 58 milliseconds I
regard this as absolutely an amazing
achievement and I think it shows you how
much Innovative work can happen in this
space not focused on hill climbing on
accuracy but rather thinking about
issues like latency and how they impact
the deployability of systems like this
and there's lots more room for
innovation in this space so I would
exhort you all to think about how you
could contribute to making systems not
only more accurate but also more
efficient along this and other
dimensions
there's one more model that I wanted to
mention because I think this is
incredibly powerful and competitive and
also offers get again another
perspective on how to use neural
representations in this space this model
is splayed
here's how splade works I've got at the
bottom here are encoding mechanism for
sequences and I'm trying to be agnostic
about whether this is a query sequence
or a document sequence because we both
do both of those with the same kind of
calculations
so just imagine we're processing some
text the core shift in perspective here
is that now we're going to do scoring
with respect not to some other text but
rather with respect to our entire
vocabulary so here I have a small
vocabulary of just seven items but of
course you could have tens of thousands
of items and that's important for
splayed because we're going to have very
sparse representations by comparison
with cross encoders DPR and Colbert
so here's how this works we're going to
form like with Colbert a matrix of
scores but now the scoring is with
respect to tokens in the sequence that
we're processing and all of our
vocabulary items the scoring function
for that is kind of detailed I've
depicted it here you should think of it
as a kind of bunch of neural layers that
help you represent all of these
comparisons so you do all of that work
and then the splade scoring function is
a kind of sparsification of the scores
that we get out of that that's depicted
here and the essential Insight is that
with this splayed function we're going
to get a score for every vocabulary item
with respect to the sequence that we
have processed and that's what's
depicted in Orange here and you should
think of this orange thing as a vector
with the same dimensionality as our
vocabulary giving what are probably very
sparse scores for our sequence with
respect to everything in that vocabulary
again we do that for queries and for
documents and then the similarity
function that's at the heart of all of
these models is now Sim splade which is
a DOT product between the splayed
representation for the query and the
splayed representation for the document
so these are big long sparse vectors and
we take the dot product of them for the
first scoring
the loss is our usual and negative log
likelihood plus importantly a
regularization term that leads to sparse
balance scores which I think is an
important modification given how
different the splayed representations
are compared to the others we've
discussed
but this is an incredibly powerful model
and I love this perspective where we're
now kind of even further back to
original IR insights about how the
vocabulary and term matching is so
important but again it's happening in
this very rich neural space it's defined
by this grid of scores
I'm not going to go through this slide
in detail but I couldn't resist
mentioning a bunch of other recent
developments they are biased toward
Colbert because I'm biased toward
Colbert but I think the list does point
to kind of General set of directions
around making systems more efficient and
also making them more multilingual and
that can happen with things like
distillation and also innovative ways of
training the models and setting up new
objectives for them while balancing lots
of considerations not just accuracy but
also efficiency for these systems
tremendously exciting and active area of
research for the field
and to round out that point I thought I
would return to the thing that I
emphasized so much when we talked about
IR metrics which is that there is more
at stake here than just accuracy so this
is from a series of controlled
experiments that we did in this paper
trying to get a sense for the system
requirements latency costs and accuracy
for a variety of systems and there's no
simple way to navigate this table so let
me just highlight a few things first
bm25 is the only model that we could
even get to run with this tiny little
compute budget so if you are absolutely
compute constrained or cost constrained
you might be forced to choose bm25 it's
a reasonably effective model
but assuming you can have more heavy
duty Hardware you might think about
trade-offs within the space of possible
Colbert setups and this is Illuminating
because for example these two models are
pretty close in accuracy but very far
apart in terms of cost and latency and
so you might think I can sacrifice this
amount of accuracy to do all this amount
of accuracy here to do this much in
terms of reduced latency and cost here's
another such comparisons Colbert small
has latency of 206 BT splayed large has
latency of 46 and costs a fraction of
what the Colbert model costs now the
Colbert model is much more accurate but
maybe this is an affordable drop here
given the other other considerations
that are in play and here's another
comparison between two BT splay large
models for a modest reduction in latency
that comes from running on a GPU I have
to pay a whole lot more money for the
same accuracy see so for example you
start to see that it's very unlikely
that you'd be able to justify using a
GPU with BT splayed large when it's only
a modest latency reduction but a huge
ballooning in the overall cost that you
pay
and I think there are lots of other
comparisons like this that we can make
and we're going to talk later in the
course about how we might systemize some
of these observations into a leaderboard
that takes account of all of these
different pressures uh and IR is a
wonderful playground for thinking about
such trade-offs